alle berichten über den ersten
humanoiden roboter mit künstlicher
intelligenz von tesla die in ihnen maske
heute morgen europäischer zeit
vorgestellt hat doch die eigentliche
sensation war die erste einblick in den
neuen tesla supercomputer joe der
absolut bahnbrechend ist und ein
prototyp davon läuft schon seit einer
woche aber der reihe nach und am ende
gibt es auch die ersten infos zum tesla
humanoiden roboter klicks und future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpassen
[Musik]
das war eine vorstellung wie apple
gründer steve jobs sie geliebt hätte und
am ende gab es noch one more thing was
tesla vorgestellt hat wird die computer
industrie weltweit komplett umkrempeln
denn hier entsteht der schnellste
supercomputer der welt de bzw
der leistungsfähigste prozessor der
einen supercomputer antreiben wird die
man mit ihnen können jetzt supercomputer
gebaut werden die doppelt so schnell wie
der schnellste supercomputer der welt
foucault sind aber auf der hälfte des
platzes gar nicht wenn katara mahnern
sehen ja director für die autopilot
hardware bei tesla ist verantwortlich
für die entwicklung er sagt über die man
dass der prozessor so leistungsfähig wie
ein grafikprozessor ist dabei aber so
flexibel wie eine cpu also eine computer
prozessor unit wie sie heute in jedem
jahr auch computer steckt und die wann
wird die doppelte bandbreite der
leistungsfähigsten netzwerk ships haben
denn das zeichnet den prozessor neben
seiner hohen rechenleistung aus er kann
daten extrem schnell transferieren was
bei künstlicher intelligenz besonders
wichtig ist dabei kommt der neue chip
nicht allein die wand wird auf eine
sogenannte kachel mit insgesamt 25 chips
montiert sechs dieser kacheln kommen in
ein computergehäuse was wahrscheinlich
eher die größe eines server schranks
entspricht als einem gehäuse für einen
homecomputer teslas braucht diese
computer power um seinen autopiloten zu
trainieren und den code dann zurück in
die fahrzeuge zu laden in riesigen
computern sammelt tesla videoclips aus
der tesla fahrzeugflotte und berechnet
daraus dem programm mit dem die teslas
dann fahren können jedes mal wenn ein
fahrzeug einen fehler macht werden die
daten vom rechenzentrum angefordert dann
gesammelt sortiert und dann ein code
berechnet damit das nicht wieder
passiert zudem werden die daten für jede
straße jede kreuzung abfahrt einfach für
jede verkehrssituation gesammelt und
übereinander gelegt die fahrzeuge
erstellen damit eine unglaublich exakte
karte des verkehrs auf der ganzen welt
so kann ein tester zum einen unbekannte
verkehrssituation anhand von beispielen
meistern da wo aber viel verkehr ist
sprich schon viele teslas waren hat die
software ein sehr exaktes bild von dem
was dort geschieht und tesla greift
jetzt auch auf simulationen zurück die
supercomputer erstellen eine virtuelle
welt wie in einem computerspiel mit
besonders schwierigen
verkehrssituationen diese kann die
software dann immer und immer wieder
trainieren selbst wenn eine solche
situation in der realität nur selten
auftaucht und tesla baut seine
rechenkapazität in allen bereichen
beständig aus und deutsch ist dafür ein
wichtiger schritt weil damit noch
schneller noch mehr rechenkapazität zur
verfügung steht und teslas immer weniger
fehler machen und schon bald die
beta-phase des vollen autonomen fahrens
endet noch machen teslas die fehler
virtuell die software für volles
autonomes fahren läuft im hintergrund im
sogenannten shadow modus und steuert das
fahrzeug nicht allerdings gibt es in den
usa 2000 fahrzeuge die die software für
volles autonomes fahren von self driving
kurz ssd bereits als beta version nutzen
schon jetzt erscheint die aktuelle
beta-version alle zwei wochen mit einer
neuen version aktuell ist die version fs
die bieter 9.2 spätestens version 10
soll schon als beta-version an alle
teslas zumindest in amerika ausgerollt
werden sprich in wenigen wochen rückt
das ziel des autonomen fahrens für alle
teslas in greifbarer nähe zumindest in
den usa davon geht zumindest ihnen maske
aus dafür betreibt tesla in 3 data
centern bereits jetzt supercomputer die
zusammen computerbauer bereitstellen die
platz zwei unter den supercomputern
weltweit einnimmt erst zwischen märz und
juli gab es einen full stopp bei der
testphase oft wer es gab so gut wie
keine updates mehr und tesla stoppte
auch die verteilung der fs die
beta-tester hatte festgestellt das radar
beim autonomen fahren er stört als hilft
es liefert immer wieder
fehlinformationen und führt zu spontanen
bremsung auch andere fahrzeuge großer
hersteller kämpfen mit diesem problem
und spontan bremsung doch hier scheint
man noch nicht zu diesem radikalen
schritt bereit zu sein tesla benötigte
für das umprogrammieren der software und
dem verzicht auf rader 2,5 millionen
videotipps auf denen dann zehn
milliarden objekte gelabelt worden denn
das ist mit einer hauptaufgabe beim
programmieren des autonomen fahrens die
software muss erkennen was sie sieht ist
das ein lkw oder ein bus ist das eine
bordsteinkante eine kurve ein fußgänger
eine fahrradfahrerin oder eine
leitplanke und die größte hürde was
macht dieser verkehrsteilnehmer in der
zukunft sprich beim autonom fahren muss
sogar die route oder das verhalten für
die anderen verkehrsteilnehmerin
berechnet werden vor vier jahren stand
es da noch ganz am anfang und die daten
die die fahrzeuge produzierten waren
eigentlich nicht zu gebrauchen denn
erfasst wurden einzelbilder und so sah
dann auch die räumliche darstellung aus
zusammengestückelt es musste etwas
geändert werden video der zeitliche
fluss musste erfasst werden nur so war
die erfassung der umwelt möglich jetzt
kann tesla so 3d räume erfassen und
vorhersagen was in zukunft passieren
wird wie bei dieser engstelle zum
beispiel ist beobachtet sehr genau das
verhalten jedes fahrzeugs bzw der
fahrerin oder das fahrrad und reagiert
darauf in sekundenbruchteilen und es ist
wirklich ziemlich beeindruckend wie
menschlich hier dann die software agiert
abhängig vom verhalten der anderen
verkehrsteilnehmer nimmt das seine route
und jetzt wird auch im 3d raum gelabelt
und die labels dann in jede kamera
übertragen das spart enorm zeit und
personal wobei tester inzwischen 1000
eigene label beschäftigt die also nichts
anderes machen als auf jedem video zu
markieren oder jetzt eben im 3d raum was
was ist tesla hat hier den riesigen
vorteil mit inzwischen knapp 1,5
millionen fahrzeugen auf den straßen die
verkehrsdaten erfassen und tester geht
einen sehr risikoreichen weg durch die
virtuelle konstruktion des 3d raums aus
video daten verwendet testern nur die
videokameras dafür verzichtet wird auf
jegliche andere sind so ein viraler eben
wie leider die die konkurrenten als
hilfsmittel einsetzen weil sie nicht in
der lage sind aus den kamera daten den
3d raum zu berechnen das hat allerdings
den erheblichen nachteil dass diese
sensoren wie das rad zum teil
widersprüchliche informationen liefern
alle maske hält diesen weg deswegen auch
für einen großen irrtum wie die
konkurrenz seinen weg für ein irrtum
hält die große frage ist noch macht die
fs die beta software ja immer wieder
fehler tesla geht davon aus dass sie
irgendwann alle ausgemerzt sind die
konkurrenz schließt das aus wie sicher
sich der tester ist zeigt das one more
thing von tesla ein humanoider roboter
mit künstlicher intelligenz moment jedem
us firma tesla will humanoide roboter
mit künstlicher intelligenz bauen da war
doch was allen masc warnte selbst vor
solchen robotern mit künstlicher
intelligenz die dann morgen durch die
straßen ziehen und alle menschen
umbringen okay viele maas betonte dann
auch dass diese roboter schwächer und
langsamer als menschen sein werden und
man weglaufen kann und somit keine
gefahr darstellen sowie so werden sie
nicht über diese möglichkeiten verfügen
denn sie sind nichts anderes als tesla
autos statt mit reifen mit armen und
beinen denn eingebaut werden dieselben
computer wie in den autos und acht
kameras nur dass die humanoiden sich
nicht nur im straßenverkehr auskennen
sondern auch in wohnungen büros fabriken
geschäften und so weiter und sie können
für ihre inhaber und inhaberin einfache
aufgaben übernehmen wie zum beispiel
einkaufen elenas kündigt dann auch das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen für die
zukunft an arbeiten müsste dann nur noch
derjenige oder diejenige der oder die
lust dazu hat und welche fähigkeiten
dieser humanoiden dann in zukunft haben
werden das war heute abzusehen nicht nur
das dojo seine arbeit beim autonom
fahren wahrscheinlich ja irgendwann mal
abgeschlossen haben wird der nächste
deutsche prozessor soll zehnmal so
schnell wie die man sein da ist also
noch einiges zu erwarten mehr über tesla
gibt es übrigens in meinem neuen buch
tesla oder wie allen masc die
elektromobilität revolutioniert wer hier
bei amazon klickt und es im nu war an de
shop kauft der oder diejenige bekommt es
übrigens mit meiner persönlichen
signatur der link ist übrigens auch in
der video beschreibung bis dann bleibt
dran